[Music]
justkeep
so this transitory thing become he goes
[Music]
oh I can't do it
pay attention someone small do you how
do I get that arm on the inside okay
watch my right knee there goes sharing
it don't scare anything else keep
looking at the right knee
[Music]
now watch
when did he go to the army there's your
you watch the transition from the next
to the arm
tell me if it stops you're also this way
okay let's go you have enjoyed this
video if you level practice breathing
boxing stop doing 50 variations in doing
50 variations let's at least do that
okay okay but how about we start
cleaning up some technical aspects okay
so he goes there's no there's no
deviation by first do you see that we
don't take on is inside the circle you
see I've been here you mean here don't
move into the arc you see
so he goes and I'm inside inside you see
don't go it's ha you're not cutting this
down this you are extending out so this
is a I can eat your own that generates
one side of the X and the y projection
keep your defense whoa extend it out
send it out you'll feel it run out next
one this is too late to ice and the
Souter sanctuary
it's already closed it's why he gets up
it's not faster
Eustace injured his wrist okay and you
don't need the other hot button house
stop doing this stuff okay it Center in
the center
[Music]
you want to
so I'm going to do yoga minute and he's
gonna let it down but you did a great
job and we're gonna see okay yes you're
trying to do
I'm coming in like this and you're
trying to smash it from the top what
happened to inertia you use it all the
time his strike yo I was right
Coleman his strikes coming down his
strikes coming down his try come down
[Music]
she's going it went too flat and keep
going
so this Friday and he tries to put it
down boom it wouldn't stop is the same
reason from the hook and you box and
wheeze over it
the punch is over here over there ok I
come in with a string it's going to go
through it will lower but it's not going
to stop and create a point of
articulation you get what we're doing is
it strikes will be did and I'm sending
out and she'll be not over the top
I'm not going like this and I go dude on
the top and he doesn't summer fun energy
goes out I do the X powder over the top
of that angle yeah so just practice that
hold this hand all you do is extend this
to there and then push over the top what
do you think's happening afterwards it
just maintain connection it wasn't doing
anything it makes
[Music]
turn it into don't move your Center to
take the pressure off move your center
let it go
Center get up take this leg out take it
out for cowardice yes well hi again that
was crap counterweight your head in your
bed lock your Center get it off the
ground balance ball
and keep that walk all the way to get up
yes okay go don't know something Hey so
I go oh look I can do that I don't I
keep the same body of in hitting yeah
whoa save mine same thing here I can do
this what would happen it will speed
he's gonna pounce on me and knock the
on me okay what do I do
kiss chill you understand so keep an
outer projection outward projection this
is not so useful tricky as a chance to
maintain center okay just like I had you
establish a relationship
your perimeter your head in any sweat
sweat he goes keep the attention wool is
it why are you having to use the other
half
where's your brakes here you have a
broken Center then you take the box whoa
this is that right here your box expose
you're not going here
[Music]
when your hair like this you moving his
arm you're like this all I need to do is
make sure that's
[Music]
stop doing this elbows in elbows in
elbows in elbows in elbows in
[Music]
so let's just look at it
taffy this knot has drawn out I break it
up into this angle of mirror you see
that's going to be young until when is
it a young no because given your cycle
through their paces where does it go
again when the head feels off so there's
no point is the following
face be generated
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
Tommy that the angle of which you hit we
will picturing this and then I hit him
that she's all set up on a transition
the that Schanke comes in that's it
that's it that's contact boom right here
you see not all this way come on what
you see is just me staying connected
[Music]
just just comment boom they'll do a
little it's not that hot
let's go there's no there's no time to
bother on this I think it's more like
[Music]
what I'm aggressive inside this strike
not drill in here
Oh try not to give me we're not we
deviated we came inside the eye on this
arm
we're not reversing on this